President Trump is attacking his
predecessors immigration record on
Twitter mr. Trump called u.s.
immigration laws quote an Obama joke
last night after declaring daca the daca
program I should say dead and urging
Congress to replace it and this morning
the president tweeted the big caravan of
people from Honduras now coming across
Mexico and heading to our weak laws
border had better be stopped before it
gets here he was apparently referring to
groups of Central American migrants seen
in southern Mexico moving north these
caravans have taken place for several
years and usually end in Mexico
Nancy cortices on Capitol Hill Nancy are
we seeing any movement on immigration
legislation in Congress at the moment we
have seen absolutely no movement John
since a series of bipartisan proposals
on daca failed to get the requisite 60
votes back in February in the Senate and
back then there was a lot of confusion
among Republicans over what exactly
president Trump would support that
confusion lingers although at least one
Republican Marco Rubio of Florida said
yesterday he still believes that
President Trump would back a pathway to
citizenship for these so-called dreamers
if it was paired with enough funding for
a new border wall the white house
however signaled yesterday
it's moving in a different direction
when it comes to immigration telling
reporters that it is currently working
with the Department of Homeland Security
to draft new legislation that will make
it tougher to apply for asylum that will
eliminate protections for certain
children so that they can be removed
quickly from the country once they
arrive and that will allow detention of
families for longer periods while they
await decisions from immigration
authorities when it comes to daca one of
the biggest problems here on Capitol
Hill has been that Democrats and
Republicans remain divided over whether
granting legal status to daca recipients
should be paired with new restrictions
on family based migration a lot of
Republicans feel very strongly about
that Democrats say it would change the
way immigration has worked in this
country for decades so while all of that
is going on or
going on as the case may be Nancy in
February a second lower court blocked
the federal government from ending the
daca program so what what's the impact
of that well on one hand it's good news
for daca recipients because those
protections that they've been receiving
stay in place past the deadline that the
Trump administration wanted to set to
remove the entire program last month on
the other hand now that that deadline no
longer exists it means that there's less
pressure on Congress to act and the
closer we get John to those November
midterm elections the less likely it's
going to get that Congress can act on
something this difficult all right Nancy
thanks so much